you have moves like I've never seen I
just was completely I just and I've seen
you perform several times and I've seen
a lot of clips of you but I saw this one
clip of you and you are going berserk
absolutely berserk Mullen lately yeah
best let's just quickly I don't know
what year this is I'm gonna guess it's
the right 1970 take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like good I don't think that girl was
very impressed think the girl was
frightened
quite a bit I think she became pregnant
watching you I gotta say I watched that
footage in my office and I was jumping
around and doing that in my office I'm
not even kidding for like 20 minutes
trying to do it and I couldn't quite get
it but my staff couldn't get me to stop
I was flipping out doing all the crazy
[ __ ] Jimmy let me show him what I was
doing
but when I do it it just looks like I'm
being tased you know or invisible snakes
are being dropped on I don't have what
you've got just don't with your tall see
yeah that doesn't work no maybe you're -
told you told you think I'm too tall
told I look like one of those sock
puppets outside a car dealership come
buy a Toyota you know you know it's
fascinating because when you first came
on the scene and you were gonna appear
on the BBC they said your moves are too
sexy yeah for the BBC this is after the
Rolling Stones had performed YES on the
BBC Mick Jagger had done they said no
that's okay not Tom Jones correct right
when it was in those days
excuse me when when you had a song to
plug you'd go on children's television
right which was like from 5:00 until
6:00 right in the evening and the
Beatles had been on there the stones had
been on everybody had been on there
and I went on there but it's not unusual
and the BBC were getting letters from
from ladies saying I don't want to see
this man gyrating in front of my
children
right so so they so it was like that and
then so that was his own unusual and
then I went back on there and they said
wait a minute what what song gonna do I
said the sky boat song you know speed
boney but sure yeah but I did have
rock'n'roll version ice you tricked them
yes did you get some moves in the hips
going yeah it was involuntary that's
like a pervert on the phone
what are you wearing Tom hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please